You know what I've been thinking a lot about lately?
That you don't love communism but you don't hate it?
No.
Oh!  That you're really excited that they finally found the cure for AIDS?
Not that you have AIDS or anything.
Guys!  I've been thinking--
I'm gonna stop you right there because I am not a guy
so why don't you go ahead and rephrase that before you continue.
Jane.  Atticus.  It was actually a rhetorical question
as a segway into what I was actually thinking.
I apologize deeply.  Go ahead.
That's okay.  No problem.
I've been thinking: why are colored pencils more difficult to erase than regular pencils?
I mean they're both just pencils.
Well I mean obviously colored pencils are
better than regular pencils because they're
harder to erase
Can we be a little bit more sensitive please?
I don't know how I feel about us calling them "colored" pencils.
Yeah, and I'm actually really shocked Jane that you would be labeling something as better
than something else.
I kind of just feel like charcoal is a classic look.
I prefer it.
For film maybe but not for art.
Film is art.  And I think you mean black and white film, not charcoal film.
Actually, I do mean charcoal.  I'm sorry.
I guess you haven't seen films from the 1700s.
Yeah.  Nobody has because they don't exist.
Do you two even know what it means to exist?